alright this is a Diamond digger saga
level 139 walkthrough tutorial video
with some commentary in it this is
probably the most frustrating level for
us than when we first played through it
so it's going to go ahead and make a
video we're explaining the tips from our
guide one thing we noticed right away
was that if you try to go after this
they're here by dropping the diamonds in
you're really not going to get them all
and you kind of need to get them all so
you're going to want to charge up your
your booster in this room and you're
going to have to get rid of this block
right here so that you can fire it down
and get get all those squares out of the
way so the best way to go about that is
to work from this side and the reason is
is because when we fire if we work if we
start on this side when we fire off our
our rocket our line blast it won't open
up the room all the way or the room
could open beforehand so if you work
from the right side whenever you get to
that point you'll usually be able to
open the open the doorway on the same
move and you don't have to worry about
the water going out so as you can see
I'm just charging it
now I have this space open i'll be able
to shoot it so you can do it either way
you could you could try to get them in
there and see if you get lucky there but
I'm really charging the Boosters the
best thing you can do and you're going
to you're going to want to get out of
here with like 12 or 13 moves left so
once you do that you got to start over
here so that you can get rid of this
block and get some diamonds to fall in
that in there there's only two colors of
diamonds here but sometimes you get a
really bad drop when they fall in so if
you can't make a match here or here next
to this block then go ahead and make
these bigger ones down here because
you're going to you're going to need
this to be charged when you get to the
last one and there's 19 there's 19 toys
total and you're going to get three in
the last room by using the booster so
you want to get this number 216 before
you move on you don't have to get it you
don't have to get all these blocks but
you want to get like where I'm at now I
want I need to get at least six more all
right so it's the same thing you got to
move these blocks one at a time we can't
block we can't make a match that's going
to get rid of these ones so we just have
to make a match below I hope they fall
in now we're not really getting very
lucky but like I said we need to charge
this anyway so just keep going ahead and
doing that alright so here we can get
some toys but we need really need to get
to this last row so we'll do that one
first and then that
on and see I kind of played it fast but
that was the point was it we might be
able to get more toys once with a big
match like this one so now we have
enough toys so we just need to get out
of the room in the next three moves and
that should actually charge the booster
and it did so open the door and then all
you have to do is put your line blaster
right here you'll get your last 3 toys
and that's the end of the level hope
this helped out to better explain it
it's a tough level it you won't always
get through it that was the first time
we tried there but um you know sometimes
they just won't line up right in the
middle but you know follow the tips and
the guide work from the right side
across and use the rocket in the exact
same places we did and you'll get
through it sooner than later hope this
helps do you have any questions leave a
comment make sure you like the video if
you found it helpful and we'll be making
more soon